Also in meinen Augen hat sich das deutlich verschlimmert mit dem Geld. Als ich noch damals 17, 18 war, da war das normal, ohne Geld zu spielen.
Seit mindestens 15 Jahren mache ich das, nicht immer in den ganz großen Maßen, aber ich würde sagen 1,5 Millionen bis 2 Millionen sind also hier von meiner Seite aus in den Sport geflossen. Das will ich auch hoffen, dass sie abhängig sind von mir. Dann würde ich es nicht machen. Ja, warum soll ich das machen? Wenn die bestimmen können, was sie wollen, warum soll ich da Geld reinschießen? Das geht nicht. Nein, dann kann ich sie gleich im Fenster rausschmeißen.
Es wird schon ein kleines Erdbeben auslösen, denn wenn es schwarze Kassen gibt, wie in ihrem Bericht dargestellt, dann ist das per se schon ein Straftatbestand.
Es geht mal wieder um die ganz heißen Themen im Fußball. Eine neue Recherche ist erschienen von der ARD in Zusammenarbeit mit der Eye-Opening Media. Ihr habt schon ein paar Zitate daraus gehört. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 45. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Aber um mich geht es hier nicht. Es geht um unter anderem diese beiden Autoren dieser Doku, die mitgearbeitet haben. Zum einen eine bekannte Stimme aus dem Rasenfunk, Arne Steinberg. Hallo Arne. Und außerdem mit dabei, ich freue mich sehr, dass er mal im Rasenfunk ist, Wigbert Löer, hallo Löer, Wigbert, Entschuldigung. Ja, ja, Wahnsinn, der Max, ich muss zugeben, es ist heute schon die zweite Aufzeichnung an diesem Tag. An solchen kleinen Details merkt man es dann, ich hoffe, du verzeichnest es mir. Es geht schon mal gut los. Wir wollen heute sprechen über eine Recherche, die ihr zwei gemacht habt. Wir werden gleich in die Tiefe einsteigen, aber ich möchte natürlich in der alten Sportjournalisten-Tradition bleiben und zuerst fragen, Wigbert, wie fühlst du dich? Bist du froh, dass es jetzt endlich an die Öffentlichkeit geht?
Ja, ich glaube, da geht es mir wie jedem anderen Journalisten, der längere Zeit an einer Recherche gesessen hat. Bei uns waren es jetzt viele, viele, viele Monate. Und wir freuen uns dann, irgendwann gibt es einen Sendeplatz für die Doku. Und dann weiß man, jetzt geht es los. Dann konzentriert sich der Schnitt und jetzt ist es endlich soweit. Sehr schön, wir freuen uns.
Ja, da kann man sich auch drauf freuen. Die Doku, ich werde es heute noch ein paar Mal erwähnen, aber sie wird am Tag, an dem das hier veröffentlicht wird, am 19.01. an diesem Mittwoch um 23.30 Uhr in der ARD laufen und es natürlich in der Mediathek abzurufen. Arne, wie lange bist du da dran gesessen an dieser Recherche?
Ja, ich glaube, Recherche an sich waren etwa zwölf Monate, also ziemlich genau ein Jahr und dann hatten wir natürlich noch, wie es beim Fernsehen so üblich ist, die Produktion, das heißt Schnitt und alles andere, was da noch so anfällt. Das heißt, ich glaube, man kann wirklich sagen, eine Recherche, die ein Jahr gedauert hat ungefähr.
Dann kann ich ungefähr nachempfinden, wie ihr euch jetzt darauf freut, dass es an die Öffentlichkeit geht. Wir wollen gleich im Detail mal drüber sprechen, was ihr da alles aufgedeckt habt. Vorher bedanke ich aber noch in guter, alten Rasenfunk-Manier, bedanke ich mich bei ein paar Menschen. Und zwar in dieser Folge bei FCB KW, bei Dominik G aus Freiburg, bei Alligator Milch, bei Sarah, bei Simon Arnold, bei Harald, bei Totti, bei Bernd1904, bei Jünter77, beim Hertha Carsten und bei Toni Holliday. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist Werbesponsor und payboy-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über euch da draußen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und ein paar davon habe ich ja jetzt gerade genannt. Dann lasst uns mal über eure Doku sprechen. Sie heißt Milliardengeschäft Amateurfußball, wenn das Geld im Umschlagkong kommt. Wigbert, worum geht es in eurem Film?
Ja, wir haben uns mal gefragt, wie viel Geld eigentlich im deutschen Amateurfußball steckt. Sind das nur ein paar Euro? Sind das größere Beträge? Welche Rolle spielt das Geld? Und wir sind dann in der Recherche natürlich auch auf das Thema gekommen. Ich sage jetzt natürlich, vielleicht ist es auch nicht natürlich, aber es war eben so, wir sind auch auf das Thema Schwarzgeld im deutschen Amateurfußball gekommen.
Wie schnell seid ihr da drauf gekommen? Also du sagst es so, dass es fast eine Selbstverständlichkeit wäre. Ein bisschen fühlt sich das ehrlich gesagt auch an, aber nur, wenn man mit so Menschen wie euch spricht, also mit Investigativarbeitenden Journalisten, egal, wo ihr hinguckt, ihr findet immer irgendwo Schwarzgeld. Aber an welchem Punkt war denn klar, das ist ein Thema, was dann auch einen solchen Aufwand ja wert ist?
Also wir sind da gestartet, wo wahrscheinlich auch die meisten Hörerinnen und Hörer starten werden, nämlich von so einem ganz normalen Wissen. Wir haben beide mal Fußball gespielt, bei Arne ist es nicht sehr lange her, der spielt sogar noch ein bisschen, bei mir ist es ein bisschen länger her, dafür habe ich auch nicht so hoch gespielt. Aber was wir beide immer mitbekommen haben, ist, dass eben Geld bezahlt wird. Und das Geld in Amateur-Ligen, auch in unteren, nicht immer nur per Amateur-Vertrag bezahlt wird, sondern das Geld eben auch bezahlt wird, im Umschlag bar, schwarz, cash in die Tasche, wie man im Rheinland sagen würde. Das war unser Start und wir haben dann, da kommen wir dann gleich sicherlich noch zu, uns ein paar Fragen gestellt und diese Fragen im Grunde an die deutschen Amateur-Fußballer, weitergegeben in Form einer großen Befragung und ja, da kam das Thema am Rande eben dann auch.
Am Rande kam das auch, Arne. Unter anderem hast du dazu ja auch im Rasenfunk aufgerufen und die Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer werden sich natürlich erinnern, wir haben schon mal ein ähnliches Tribünengespräch mit einem, na zumindest artverwandten Thema gemacht, nämlich zu eurer Pillen-Kick-Recherche zum Schmerzmittelmissbrauch im Amateur-Sport ja gerade auch. Magst du mal ein paar Worte sagen, wie war denn euer Vorgehen jetzt bei dieser Recherche?
Ja grundsätzlich war das schon sehr ähnlich gelagert, würde ich sagen. Wir hatten den großen Vorteil, dass wir bei dieser Recherche wieder mit korrektiv kooperieren konnten. Die hatten eben dann die technische Umgebung, sage ich mal, gestellt für diese Befragung, ja also einen einfacheren Anführungsstrichen Online-Fragebogen, den wir dann versucht haben, in die Fläche zu bringen, dass eben möglichst viele Menschen daran teilnehmen können. Und der Ansatz war eben, wie Wigbert eben schon sagte, dass wir mal valide Zahlen erheben, denn ich denke, wir haben alle schon mitbekommen, dass es immer wieder Gerüchte gibt und vielleicht auch mal eine kleine lokale Berichterstattung gibt über Vereine, die sehr viel Geld zur Verfügung haben, auch im Amateurfußball. Und wir wollten eben versuchen, möglichst viele Daten dazu zu sammeln, damit wir da mal ein großflächiges Bild bekommen. Und analog zu Pillenkrieg damals haben wir da eben mit Korrektiv zusammengearbeitet. Und es gab da sicherlich diese handwerkliche Parallele, aber es gab auch eine inhaltliche Parallele, denn wir hatten damals schon in den Daten zu Pillenkrieg gesehen, dass viele Amateurfußballer dann tatsächlich auch in der männlichen Form deswegen spielen, auch mit Schmerzen spielen und dann auch mit Schmerzmitteln spielen, weil sie eben Auflaufprämie bekommen. Und das war ganz zu Beginn der Recherche dann auch ein Ansatzpunkt, kurz nach der Veröffentlichung von Pillenkrieg mal zu sagen, Mensch, dieser monetäre Aspekt, dieses finanzielle Thema, das wäre doch mal ein Ziel, das zu erfragen einfach mit den Leuten, die das betrifft. Und natürlich kann man nicht 10.000 Telefonate führen. Das ist, denke ich, sehr, sehr schwierig. Deswegen haben wir diesen Fragebogen aufgesetzt, natürlich auch in dem Wissen, dass wir irgendwie herausfinden müssen oder sollten, wie viel von diesen Zahlungen dann tatsächlich unter der Hand geschieht. Und ja, dann ging es eben auch mithilfe des Rasenfunks dann darum, dass wir an möglichst viele Daten kommen, eben mithilfe der Community, mithilfe der Leute im Amateurfußball, der AmateurfußballerInnen. Und ja, das ist uns dann mit mehr als 10.000, denke ich, ganz gut gelungen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine solide Datenbasis. Ganz kurz ein kurzer Einschub. Wigbert, könntest du ein bisschen das Mikro von deinem Mund wegmachen? Man hört dich immer atmen. Und ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich das dann später rausmuten kann. Super, sehr gut. Dann machen wir einfach direkt weiter, als wäre nichts passiert. Was habt ihr denn dann von diesen 10.000 Menschen denn erfragt, Wigbert? Was war da das Vorgehen der Umfrage?
Ja, wir haben gefragt, bei wie vielen Vereinen habt ihr schon gespielt? Habt ihr irgendwann mal Geld bekommen? Bekommt ihr jetzt gerade, und da haben wir einen sogenannten Beispielmonat, einen Referenzmonat genommen, kommt ihr im Oktober 2020, habt ihr da Geld bekommen? Und dann haben wir noch Fragen gestellt, wie, im Falle einer Bezahlung, wie habt ihr das Geld bekommen? Ist das vertraglich geregelt worden, dokumentiert worden? Ging das einfach nur nach mündlicher Absprache, Bar, im Umschlag, solche Fragen haben wir gestellt.
Und da wird ja sehr wahrscheinlich dann auch ein wesentlicher Unterschied liegen. Also ich hätte jetzt mal aus meiner Leihenssicht gesagt, bevor ich euren Film gesehen hatte, naja, also im begrenzten Rahmen werden Zahlungen ja schon erlaubt sein, wahrscheinlich macht es die Form und auch die Versteuerung da dann den Unterschied. Kann man das so einfach stehen lassen?
Ja, das ist, denke ich, mal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt gleich zu beginnen. Also wir sagen ja nicht, dass es komplett verboten ist, im Amateurfußball Geld zu bezahlen. Das soll auch nicht der Eindruck sein, der jetzt durch diesen Film entstehen soll. Es geht allerdings dann ganz klar um die Art und Weise wie. Und natürlich ist es so, dass Geldzahlungen im Amateurfußball grundsätzlich auch erst mal nichts schlechtes sind, weil ich glaube, dass Trainerinnen und Trainer, Übungsleiter, schon auch finanziell für entlohnt werden sollten, wenn sie eben dreimal die Woche auf dem Platz stehen. Da gibt es ja auch Pauschalen für, das ist ja auch alles okay. Dann gibt es Aufwandsentfädigungen, die bezahlt werden können für Kleidung oder andere Aufwendungen, die man eben hat und auch eben Auslagen. Im Vereinsrecht können eben auch Fahrtkosten bezahlt werden. Tankgutscheine gibt es, 44 Euro im Monat kann man glaube ich steuerfrei machen. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch den Amateurvertrag, den der DFB vorsieht in seiner Spielordnung. Da ist eben ganz klar geregelt, wenn ein Spieler mehr als 250 Euro im Monat verdienen möchte und soll, dann müssen eben der Verein und der betreffende Spieler einen Amateurvertrag abschließen. Und dann müssen eben auch Stollen und Sozialabgaben abgeführt werden. Das heißt, das ist dann für die Sozialversicherung auch relevant. Und kommt dann eben einem normalen Spielervertrag, wie man ihn kennt, eben näher. Es ist aber kein Spielervertrag, wie ihn jetzt zum Beispiel Profis in der Bundesliga haben, weil das sind dann natürlich Kapitalgesellschaften und da greifen nochmal andere Regelungen. Aber ein normaler Amateurverein kann eben auch einen Vertrag mit Spielern abschließen, die dann entlohnen und dann ist auch alles okay. Aber wir haben uns eben genau diese Frage gestellt, wo verläuft da so der Graubereich oder wo ist da die Grenze und wann wird es tatsächlich kritisch?
Ja und das ist ja tatsächlich dann die spannende Frage, auch weil ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass zumindest im unteresten Amateurbereich da vielleicht das ein oder andere auch aus Blauäugigkeit herausgescheht. Also wenn ich mir überlege in meiner bescheidenen Fußballkarriere, ich habe immer in den niedrigsten Klassen, die es gab, gespielt oder bin einmal aufgestiegen und dann wieder abgestiegen, so ging das eigentlich die ganze Zeit hin und her zwischen Bezirksklasse C und was weiß ich, was dann die Klasse drüber war, wann, wie die sich genau genannt hat. Da gab es das durchaus auch, dass bei uns bald ein Spieler gewechselt ist. Ich glaube, ich wollte auch mal irgendwann wechseln. Ich kriege es gerade gar nicht mehr selber auf die Reihe. Und da hieß es dann auch, ja, wenn wir für dich 300 Euro Ablöse kriegen, dann können wir das machen. Was ich damals schon wahnsinnig albern fand, weil das hatte, glaube ich, mit einem Umzug zu tun, dass ich den Verein wechseln wollte. Ich hatte aber auch nicht das Gefühl, dass diejenigen, mit denen ich da in meinen Vereinen zu tun hatte... Also, die waren jetzt nicht so die klassischen Menschen, die, glaube ich, die DFB-Statuten und die des Bayerischen Fußballverbandes auswendig gelernt hatten, um das jetzt sozusagen... Wigbert, wie war denn jetzt eure Erfahrung? Ihr habt da jetzt dann ganz genau reingeschaut. Ist da auf unterster Ebene vielleicht auch einfach viel per Handschlag? Und ich sage jetzt mal, ohne auch ein Wissen um mögliche Konsequenzen, was da passiert?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall so. Das ist eindeutig eines der deutlichen Ergebnisse unserer Befragung. Wenn du erlaubst, du hast ja am Anfang auch dich bedankt, würde ich mich an dieser Stelle einmal ganz kurz bedanken. Und zwar, nachdem wir diese Umfrage gemacht haben, diese Befragung aufgesetzt haben, dann haben wir ja versucht, die in die weite Welt des deutschen Amateurfußballs hinaus zu bekommen. Und da haben uns wirklich viele, viele Kollegen und Redaktionen mitgeholfen. Lokalzeitungen, ja, etliche. Auch das Portal fupanet hat mitgeholfen. Den Rasenfunk hast du eben schon erwähnt oder hat Arne schon erwähnt. Wir haben darüber hinaus auch die Möglichkeit gehabt, die uns die ID gibt, eben konkret Leute anzuschreiben. Also per Mail, per WhatsApp. Wir haben wirklich versucht, das ganz, ganz breit zu streuen. Da haben uns andere Kollegen, wie damals z.B. den Krämer, noch geholfen. Ich sage das, weil ich das erwähnenswert finde, weil so was ja, es gibt immer so einen großen kritischen Blick auf den Journalismus. Der mag hier und da auch gerechtfertigt sein. Aber hier muss man sagen, hat der Journalismus, in diesem Fall der Sportjournalismus, einfach ganz tolle Arbeitsmöglichkeiten. Und das erlaube ich mir hier kurz einmal schnell zu sagen.
Ja, das ist ja auch richtig. Und 10.000 Befragte und Teilnehmende, das ist ja auch ein nennenswerter Teil. Aber um dann auf die Frage zurückzukommen, wenn wir jetzt mal auf den Unterst liegen ansetzen, dann sind das Amateurvereine, die ehrenamtlich von Freiwilligen oder nicht ganz so Freiwilligen, je nach Struktur des Dorfes, irgendwie geführt werden. Wie oft, eurer Einschätzung nach, kommt es denn dann vor, dass da Menschen vielleicht auch allein schon von der Frage irritiert waren, weil ihnen vielleicht sogar das mit dem Amateurvertrag jetzt zum Beispiel gar nicht klar war?
Das können wir nicht final sagen, weil wir haben das jetzt nicht quasi gefragt, wusstet ihr überhaupt von dem ganzen Kram? Ich glaube, dass die Leute schon wissen, dass das nicht ganz in Ordnung ist. Die allermeisten. Die agieren aber natürlich in einem Feld, was erstmal ein positives Feld ist. Die engagieren sich, die machen gute Sachen. Wir müssen froh sein, dass es Vereine gibt, dass es Sportvereine gibt. Das unterscheidet Deutschland von vielen anderen Ländern und Gesellschaften und macht eine starke Zivilgesellschaft aus. Deshalb agieren diese Leute erstmal, finde ich, von Grund auf mit bestem Wissen und Gewissen. Aber natürlich, wenn ich ein paar hundert Euro Scheine in Umschlag stecke und die jemanden gebe, nachdem der mir gesagt hat, eben der Spieler, boah, ich kann das aber überhaupt nicht gebrauchen, dass ich das offiziell kriege, ich brauche das bitte so irgendwie unter der Hand und ich mache das dann, dann ist mir, glaube ich, als Vereinenfunktionär schon klar, dass das auch möglicherweise nicht alles mit rechten Dingen zugibt. Es gibt aber, das ist auch eine starke Stelle, da gebe ich gleich mal an Arne weiter, in unserem Film, wir sprechen da oder wir treffen einen oder zwei Vereinsfunktionäre, wo es eben, wo eben die Steuerverhandlung gekommen ist, die nachzahlen mussten, die nicht alles richtig gemacht hatten. Und der eine, das ist der Kassierer, glaube ich, Arne, der sagt einen Satz und bringt eine These, die ich eigentlich total interessant fand.
Ja, also zwei sehr unterhaltsame und interessante Gesprächspartner, finde ich. Also das können sich dann alle nochmal im Bild anschauen im Film. Also diese Frage, die sich da bei diesem Verein gestellt hat, ist eben genau das. Also wo fängt Unwissenheit an und wo endet das eben? Und wo ist eben dieser Bereich der Naivität dann verlassen? Diesen Verein hat es dann getroffen, dass er nachzahlen musste. Und danach war eben eine Läuterung, wenn man so will, dass eben gesagt wurde, wir machen jetzt alles sauber nach den Büchern. Und das ist natürlich ein großer Aufwand, das kostet Zeit. Aber worauf Wigbert eben hinaus wollte, ist, dass der Hauptkassierer dann sagte, Unwissenheit schützt nicht vor Strafe. Und das ist natürlich auch so. Denn ich glaube, wir haben in Deutschland schon auch branchenübergreifend Schwarzgeld und Schwarzarbeit als Thema. Also wenn man die Baubranche beispielsweise nimmt, oder auch den Dienstleistungsbereich, gerade wenn es um illegal beschäftigte Putzfrauen geht, oder Putzkräfte generell, dann ist das natürlich auch ein Thema. Und natürlich kann man sagen, wenn ich jetzt mein Geld bar bekomme, dann ist das erstmal okay, da muss ich nichts abführen, dann habe ich mehr in der Tasche am Ende des Monats, alles gut. Aber das ist natürlich auch eine Gefahr. Das ist eine Gefahr insofern, dass eben im Falle einer Krankheit oder auch im Falle von unerwarteten Ereignissen dann so ein Verhältnis auch schnell mal aufgehoben werden kann. Das heißt also, man ist eigentlich in einem Arbeitsverhältnis, hat aber nur quasi die Bezahlung, auf die man sich berufen kann, hat aber keine Rechte, keine Pflichten. Und beim Fußball ist es natürlich so, man hat dreimal die Woche Training, man trifft sich zu einer bestimmten Zeit, man ist weisungsgebunden dem Trainer gegenüber, man kann nicht einfach machen, was man will. Und in der Rechtsprechung ist das eben sehr, sehr nahe an einem Arbeitsverhältnis. Und wenn dann eben monatlich 300 Euro, jetzt mal so salopp gesagt, im Umschlag bezahlt werden, dann stellt sich da schon die Frage nach der Lösung dieses Problems.
Jetzt lasst mal erstmal noch eingrenzen, wie groß das Problem eigentlich ist. Da bin ich jetzt selber ein bisschen drüber gesprungen. Es gibt rund 700.000 Spielerinnen, die im DFB und in den jeweiligen Landesverbänden organisiert sind. Davon haben rund 1% einen Amateurvertrag, habe ich in eurem Film gelernt. Jetzt habt ihr mit 10.000 ja eine solide Datenbasis. Wie viele sind es denn jetzt dann, die Geld bekommen und das bei euch in der Umfrage angegeben haben?
Ja, kleine Korrektur. Also es sind 700.000 Amateurfußballer tatsächlich, also männlich ab 18, die im Amateurfußball unterwegs sind. Da kommen natürlich Frauen hinzu, Kinder und Jugendliche. Das heißt, am Ende hat der DFB vielleicht, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie die aktuellen Zahlen sind, aber 1, x Millionen Aktive, davon eben diese 700.000 Männer. Und auf die beziehen wir uns eben in der Stichprobe. Das heißt, wir gucken uns alle an, die mindestens 18 sind.
Weil ihr da auch quasi von der Befragung her einen Schwerpunkt hattet, ähnlich wie bei der Pin-Kick-Recherche auch schon. Deswegen habt ihr das auf Männer begrenzt oder hat es noch andere Gründe?
Nee, das war der allergrößte Teil in der Umfrage. Und das sind dann halt eben auch die, von denen wir jetzt ausgehen können, dass die gerade aktiv sind, die 18- bis 39-Jährigen. Es haben sich auch weitaus weniger Frauen beteiligt. Es gibt ja auch weniger Fußballspielerinnen, deshalb hat uns das jetzt auch nicht überrascht. Und was wir von deren Antworten gelernt haben, ist, dass dieses Thema auch nicht überraschend im Frauenfußball nicht besteht, weil eben so viel Geld im Frauenfußball gar nicht unterwegs ist, im Frauenamateurfußball oder in den niederen Klassen.
Und wie viele Spieler waren das jetzt dann, die angegeben haben, dass sie Geld bekommen?
Wir hatten eine Stichprobe von mehr als 8.000 dann, also 8.000 männliche Amateurfußballer zwischen 18 und 39. Und von denen haben angegeben, dass 60%, also mehr als die Hälfte, schon einmal oder öfters Geld bekommen hat. Das heißt, wenn wir uns das ein bisschen plastischer vorstellen, wir nehmen eine x-beliebige Mannschaft in Deutschland, rein statistisch ist es ja möglich, dann haben sechs von zehn Spielern aus dieser Mannschaft schon mal Geld bekommen. So im Amateurfußball. Wenn wir eben sagen, der Amateurfußball ist ein Rückgrat der Gesellschaft, das ist alles ehrenamtlich und ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Sozialfaktor in diesem Land. Und dann hört man eben diese Zahl. Und das ist dann schon irgendwo als erstes Ergebnis erstmal krass. Also war es auch für mich, denn klar ist die ganze Schwarzgeldkomponente auch noch wichtig, aber dass man erstmal jetzt dazu kommt, das so beziffern zu können, ist ein relevantes Ergebnis. Jetzt kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren, ob das Umfrage-Design das nicht gefördert hat, dass eventuell mehr Leute teilnehmen, die schon mal Geld bekommen haben. Einfach so ein Selection-Bias, das kann natürlich alles sein. Aber ist für uns jetzt erstmal nicht erheblich, weil wir da versucht haben, eine möglichst große Datenlage zu schaffen. Und da ist eben diese 60% das erste Ergebnis, was hängen geblieben ist.
Und kann man sagen, wie viele von diesen 60% dann auch bei Beträgen sind die über den 250 Euro landen, die mit einem Amateurvertrag ja noch darstellbar wären?
Ja, da muss man ein bisschen differenzieren nach den Ligen. Nach den Ligen, in denen die Spieler aktiv sind. Das haben wir auch gemacht. Dann in der Datenauswertung, da haben wir geschaut, wo liegt ungefähr so der Median, das heißt der mittlere Wert von den Zahlungen, die da eben stattfinden. Der war natürlich in den Ligen 5 bis 6 relativ hoch, also auch über 250 Euro. Und das ist eben der mittlere Wert. Das heißt, da gibt es dann eben die Hälfte der Zahlungen, die dann noch mal wesentlich höher ist. Und selbst in Ligen 7 und 8 sind wir immer noch bei zweieinhalb Euro. Das heißt, da kann man schon den Schluss draus ziehen, dass das eben viele Spieler betrifft, die auch mehr als 250 Euro im Monat bekommen. Und um das Ganze noch mal rund zu machen, diese Abfrage bei den Landesverbänden nach den Amateurverträgen, die bezog sich eben auf die Saison 2020-2021. Und dort gab es dann eben den Rücklauf von circa 8.000, 8.500. Einige konnten das auch nicht genau beziffern. Deswegen mussten wir da so ein bisschen in der Größenordnung von agieren. Und das ist dann natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wenig. Denn die Spielordnung des DFB sieht es vor. Aber es ist ja schon eine große Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was auf dem Papier steht und was dann in der Realität stattfindet.
Man kann sagen, dass das Instrument, Amateurvertrag, was der DFB sicherlich aus sehr guten Gründen geschaffen hat, dass das, man kann nicht sagen, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber es wird halt sehr, sehr wenig angewandt. Es kommt einfach nicht zum Einsatz oder nahezu nicht zum Einsatz. Es gibt den Amateurvertrag, aber er wird kaum genutzt.
Ich finde, über die Rolle der Verbände sollten wir später auch noch sprechen. Jetzt interessiert mich aber erst mal, nachdem ihr ja auch so viel Zugang dann auch hattet zu einzelnen Spielern, was sind denn das für Spieler, die Geld bekommen? In welchen Größenordnungen sprechen wir da? Arne, habt ihr da Beispiele, wo man das mal ein bisschen deutlich illustrieren könnte? Ein Spieler kommt ja auch unter anderem in eurem Film vor.
Also man findet wahrscheinlich Beispiele für nahezu jede Summe. Es hat auch mal jemand gesagt, ich kriege irgendwie in der 6. Liga 1200 Euro. Ich gucke jetzt gerade nicht in die Statistika, sondern nach meiner Erinnerung. Es gibt auch welche, die in der 8. Liga 150 Euro bekommen. Das ist also wirklich quer durch den Garten. Was sind das für Leute? Ich glaube, das sind einfach alles Mögliche. Das sind jetzt nicht nur Studenten, die sagen, damit finanziere ich mir mein WG oder Wohnheimszimmer. Das sind auch nicht Leute, die gerade noch in der Ausbildung sind und sagen, sie verdienen sich auch was dazu. Das sind manchmal auch Leute, die ganz stark gestartet sind auf hohem sportlichen Niveau, in der Jugend, vielleicht im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum gewesen sind, dann aber eben nicht den Sprung in den Profifußball geschafft haben oder auch vielleicht gar nicht schaffen wollten. Und die dann eben für kleineres Geld gemütlich weiter, aber völlig normal bezahlt, über die Jahre ihre Karriere ausklicken lassen. Ich glaube, man findet alles Mögliche.
Wenn ich da schnell ergänzen darf, das ist eben einfach ein Markt auch. Ich glaube, es hilft, wenn man den Amateurfußball als Markt versteht. Und wenn man das tut, dann kommen sicherlich auch so Konstrukte zustande, wo dann eben ein Spieler, der eigentlich, sagen wir mal, auf Ligen-Niveau 5 spielen könnte, aber dort in Anführungsstrichen nur 200 Euro bekommen würde, dass der dann breitwillig sagt, ich gehe in Liga Niveau 7, weil ich dort 300 Euro bekomme. Und das in solchen Fällen gibt es. Solche Fälle können wir glaube ich alle irgendwo, die wir im Amateurfußball unterwegs sind, zitieren. Und das läuft dann schon so ein bisschen dem entgegen, was ich so unter Leistungsorientiertem Sport oder Sport generell verstehe. Denn wenn jemand in der siebten Liga für sein Hobby 300 Euro im Monat bekommt, dann ist das sicherlich gut für die Person erstmal. Aber wir haben eben in Deutschland da auch ein groteskes Missverhältnis, wie ich finde, zwischen dem Fußball und den anderen Sportarten. Wir sehen es ja schon im Fußball selber, dass es im Frauenfußball gar nicht stattfindet. Und wenn man sich dann anschaut, dass Mannschaften aus der zweiten Liga im Volleyball, Basketball, keine Ahnung, oder andere eher Randsportarten, dass die quasi noch Geld mitbringen, dann finde ich, sollte der Amateurfußball sich schon mal irgendwie überlegen, ob das alles so zielführend und nachhaltig ist. Ich meine, wenn das Geld da ist, dann hat das ja sicherlich auch einen Grund, Zug auf die Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ich glaube, langfristig gesund ist es nicht.
Ja, schwierige Diskussionen, da kommt man natürlich an einen Punkt der Frage, was will man erwarten? Also ich kann jeden Spieler verstehen, der sagt, mit der Sache, die mir viel Spaß macht, dann auch noch Geld verdienen. Ich freue mich auch, Geld zu verdienen. Geld an sich ist ja nichts Schlechtes. Und gleichzeitig kann man auch nachvollziehen, dass wenn sich da ein Wettbewerb herausbildet, dann kennt man das ja. Also das haben ja vielleicht auch Hörerinnen und Hörer auch schon selbst erlebt. Zumindest mir ist es nicht ganz unbekannt. Du spielst eben in deiner Liga, die einen begrenzten regionalen Einzug hat. Und daher kommen die Vereine. Und dann überlegt sich irgendein Schreiner oder ein Dachdecker oder ein anderer Unternehmer, der eben Geld hat. Ich will jetzt den Verein, in dem ich selber gespielt habe, nach vorne bringen. Und dann macht das was mit der ganzen Liga. Und auch so, dass das ja auch durchaus auch die anderen Vereine unter Zugzwang sechst. Also ihr habt einen Spieler im Film mit dabei, der sagt, na das ist auch ein Problem, weil es kommen dann die guten Spieler, die werden bezahlt, kommen in der untere Liga und die schießen einem die komplette Liga kaputt. Hat er wortwörtlich gesagt. Und das habe ich auch schon mal erlebt.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Spieler, ist der Benjamin Bikic, ob der das als Problem sieht, weil streng genommen ist er auch einer. Der hat zum Beispiel auch bei Hannover 96 noch im Jugendleistungszentrum gespielt. Ein ja, ein offenbar sehr guter Spieler. Und der spielt im Moment in der Kreisliga. Und sag ich mal, ist da relativ unumstritten und macht seine Tore. Ja, der schießt auch die Liga kaputt.
Das klingt ja mega geil für einen Spieler, das muss man ja schon zugeben.
Ja, wir haben da auch immer viel drüber. Du hast eben gesagt, das ist eine große Diskussion. Das war auch zwischen mir und Arne und unseren Kollegen, Hajo Seppelt und Ben Azioli, die bei dem Film ja auch und bei der Recherche auch mitgemacht haben. Immer ein großes Diskussionsthema. Und das wird man nie fertig und ausdiskutieren können. Ist das jetzt schlimm oder ist das nicht schlimm? Natürlich ist es bescheuert. Oder was heißt bescheuert? Es ist Wettbewerbsverzerrung, wenn ein Metsen, ein lokaler Metsen einen Verein aufrüstet. Das prominenteste Beispiel ist wahrscheinlich Dietmar Hopp, der ja vor 15 Jahren ungefähr auch durch solche Ligen gezogen ist mit seinem Dorfverein. Der kam ja auch irgendwie aus der Kreise der Bezirksliga. Ist das ein Problem? Ist das umgekehrt ein Problem, wenn ein Student, der in Köln wohnt, für teuer Geld Miete zahlen muss? Wenn der nach einem Jahr, wo er in Leverkusen beim, weiß ich nicht, ich sage jetzt mal Oberligisten gespielt hat und hört, irgendwo gibt es einen Landesligisten im Kölner Süden, die wollen angreifen, die wollen aufsteigen. Und da gibt es einfach dann nochmal das Doppelte oder zumindest nochmal die Hälfte obendrauf. Kann man dem böse sein, dass er da hingeht? Der ist ja eh nicht mit dem Leverkusener Verein aufgewachsen, weil er sowieso ursprünglich aus Westfalen kommt und nur zum Studium nach Köln gegangen ist, um jetzt bei diesem fiktiven Beispiel zu bleiben. Also es gibt da und umgekehrt, was Arne eben gesagt hat, klar, jemand, der ganz doll und gut Volleyball spielt, der zur Elite gehört, in der zweiten Liga spielt, der kriegt weniger mitunter als ein Bezirks- oder Kreisoberligaspieler im deutschen Amateurfußball. Also, tja, so ist es.
Ich will noch eine Sache kurz nachschieben, wenn wir über Mezene sprechen. Das ist ja gerade schon angeklungen. Das ist für mich immer ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Natürlich ist es gut, wenn Leute Geld zur Verfügung stellen. Für den Vereinssport finde ich, das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung, das kann aber auch dann schwierig werden, wenn es eben weniger um den Erfolg des Vereins oder um den Zustand des Vereins geht, sondern eher um die individuelle Darstellung und die Aufmerksamkeit, die man darüber auf sich ziehen will. Das sage ich jetzt erstmal ganz wertfrei, aber ich glaube, das ist in dieser ganzen Diskussion ein Punkt, der sehr wichtig ist. Ich glaube, Metzene, die nicht das Geld in die erste Herrenmannschaft investieren, sondern die sagen, wir wollen hier ein vernünftiges Trainingszentrum bauen, wir wollen hier auch vernünftige Trikots, vernünftige Bälle für alle Mannschaften haben, das ist aus meiner Sicht schon ein bisschen was anderes, als jetzt jemand, der sagt, ich will in fünf Jahren mit meiner ersten Herrenmannschaft in der Oberliga spielen.
Aber wir haben genau solche Vereine auch kennengelernt. Es war ja so, dass die Teilnehmer unserer Befragung konnten anonym teilnehmen, sie konnten aber auch Kontaktdaten hinterlassen, ihren Namen, die E-Mail-Adresse, Telefonnummern. Und so hatten wir die Möglichkeit, das haben nämlich relativ viele gemacht, viel mehr als wir gedacht haben, bei diesem Thema Geld, über Geld spricht man ja so gerne, gar nicht heißt es immer, aber viele haben eben doch gerne darüber gesprochen. Und wir sind, Arne und ich, mit vielen, vielen Leuten ins Gespräch gekommen. Und die haben uns auch offen was erzählt. Und sie haben oft auch gesagt, bei uns wird nicht bezahlt, aber guckt euch mal den Verein an, oder den Verein. Und es gibt auch Vereine, ja, und wir haben teilweise auch mit Leuten aus diesen Vereinen gesprochen, die haben einfach nur eine erste Herrenmannschaft. Da gibt es einen Verein, der hat eine erste Herrenmannschaft, der will keine Zweiter haben, der besorgt sich seine Spieler von anderen Vereinen, der will keinen Nachwuchs aufbauen, der will auch keine Sozialarbeit machen und die Leute irgendwie zum Sport animieren oder so, sondern der will einfach nur wirtschaftlichen Erfolg haben. Solche Vereine gibt es auch. Und die haben, natürlich, solange sie einen Sponsor haben, der das Geld gibt, haben die absolut Erfolg.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, die wichtige Unterscheidung, dass Geld im Amateurfußball steckt. Das ist nun mal so, aber wem kommt es zugute und mit welchem Zweck kommt es dem zugute? Und der Sport hat eben auch eine gesellschaftliche Rolle, die dann eben bei einem solchen Beispiel, wie du es gerade genannt hast, da kann man sehr gut darüber streiten, ob diese gesellschaftliche Funktion des Sports da überhaupt noch erfüllt wird. Und das ist halt dann insofern relevant, weil der Sport aufgrund dieser gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung gewisse Privilegien genießt. Nicht nur steuerrechtlicher, sondern auch sonstiger Natur. Und da kommt man natürlich dann sehr schnell in interessante Fallbeispiele rein. Aber wenn wir jetzt schon über das Geld im Amateurfußball sprechen, woher kommt denn das überhaupt?
Ja, sehr wichtige Frage, die natürlich auch für uns in der Recherche irgendwo dann erstmal so der Moment war, wo wir dachten, okay, wir reden jetzt über irgendwelche Summen, wo kommt das ganze Geld denn her? Also grundsätzlich ist es so, die Wissenschaft sagt, der gesunde Menschenverstand sagt, ein Verein bezieht seine Einnahmen erstmal aus den Mitgliedsbeiträgen und aus den Einnahmen rund um irgendwelche Spieltage oder Veranstaltungen oder was auch immer. Dann gibt es natürlich den Bereich, wo Sponsoren dann auch aktiv werden, wo Sponsoren sagen, ich unterstütze hier meinen Verein mit einer Bandenwerbung oder mit einem Trikotsatz oder was auch immer. Dann gibt es Konstrukte mit Fördervereinen, wo ein Förderverein im Prinzip dazu da ist, Gelder zu akquirieren für einen Verein, in dem eben der letztliche Sport ausgeübt wird. Und dann gibt es Vereine, wo eben eine Person als Mäzen, als Großspender, vielleicht sogar als Sponsor mit dem Unternehmen noch den Hauptteil des Etats bestreitet. Und was für uns während der Recherche natürlich auch immer noch ein Thema war, was bisher noch gar nicht angeklungen ist, ist eben die Corona-Pandemie auch. Weil natürlich der Zeitraum, in dem wir die Daten erhoben haben, maßgeblich davon beeinträchtigt war. Das heißt also, dieser Monat, Oktober 2020, auf den wir viele unserer Daten und Berechnungen beziehen, war natürlich schon von der Corona-Pandemie geprägt. Das heißt also, da haben weniger Spiele stattgefunden, da haben die Vereine vielleicht weniger Geld zur Verfügung gehabt, was eventuell möglicherweise die Ergebnisse sogar noch ein bisschen nach unten korrigiert. Das heißt, es könnte in einem normalen Monat vor Corona eventuell noch mehr gewesen sein. Und die Frage, die sich dann stellt, ist, was machen die Vereine mit dem Geld? Woher kriegen sie das? Und wie gehen sie damit um, wenn der Hauptteil des Etats eben dafür draufgeht, Spieler aus der ersten Herrenmannschaft zu bezahlen?
Und man muss einfach sagen, ein großer Teil fließt einfach da rein. Das ist ganz eindeutig, das geben die Zahlen her. Und wir haben uns eine Liga, das hat sich so ein bisschen zufällig ergeben, weil irgendwie hatten wir viele Teilnehmer aus der Liga, wir hatten Hinweise auf Vereine aus der Liga. Und wir haben uns eine Liga, eine achte Liga in einer großen Stadt in Süddeutschland genauer angeschaut. Da haben wir Sprachnachrichten bekommen von Vereinen. Eine sprechen wir auch nach, leider können wir sie nicht im Original wiedergeben. Wo der Vereinsverantwortliche dem Spieler, mit dem Spieler, über das Geld redet, verschiedene Modelle anbietet. Wir haben Leute, die in dieser Liga ihrem Geld hinterhergelaufen sind. Wir haben teilweise Dokumente, die belegen, dass Geld in der Liga fließt. Und wir haben dann auch noch, da kommen vielleicht später noch mal drauf, einen Lokvogel, d.h. einen Amateurspieler, zu einem Verein dieser Liga geschickt, der dort gesagt hat, er möchte sich dem Verein gerne anschließen und dann eben auch um Geld verhandelt hat mit oder vor versteckter Kamera. Und in dieser Liga, das fand ich also besonders eindrücklich, das hat jetzt unsere Recherche gegeben, wird wirklich, es ist eine achte Liga, wird wirklich sehr, sehr viel Geld bezahlt. Und es ist schon klar, es wird nicht überall gleich viel Geld bezahlt. In Deutschland, die fünfte Liga im Südwesten, hat mir ein Amateurspielerberater erzählt, da kann man richtig, richtig, richtig gutes Geld verdienen. Das ist eigentlich so von der Relation her die bestbezahlte Liga in Deutschland. In der Tat ist es so, dass im Südwesten, in Bayern sicherlich auch, in Hessen und in NRW viel mehr Geld zu verdienen ist als in Norddeutschland und auch in Teilen von Ostdeutschland.
Kleiner Tipp für alle Amateur-Fußballer in der Vereinigung.
Das haben wir ja auch gelernt von den Amateur-Fußballern. Das kann man hier genauso weitergeben. Aber das Geld fließt einfach in die Mannschaften. Das ist das, was man zeigt, wodurch man sich zum großen Teil definiert. Ich habe eben schon diese einen Mannschaftsvereine genannt. Und da fließt die ganze Kohle hin.
Jetzt hast du gerade schon einen Begriff fallen lassen, den hätten vielleicht nicht alle Hörerinnen und Hörer in diesem Gespräch erwartet. Nämlich den Begriff Spielerberater. Das gibt es auch für Amateurfußballer?
Ja, das gibt es auch für Amateurfußballer. Die Bibel-Internetseite für Spielerberater ist ja transfermarkt.de. Wenn man da ein bisschen sucht, dann ist man ganz schnell nicht nur bei den großen Widmanns und Struts und Webels und Croats und so weiter, sondern man ist dann irgendwann auch bei Berater, die im Portfolio haben, Spieler aus den 6. und 7. liegen. Die gibt es und bei uns macht auch einer, also hat uns einer auch ein Interview gegeben, den haben wir auch reingebracht in die Dokumentation und da haben wir auch gelernt, im Kleinen geht es wie im Großen, muss man sagen.
Genau, das war Danny Jeske, den haben wir auch im Intro schon gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war derjenige, der gesagt hat, es habe sich deutlich verschlimmert. Und im Film zitierte ihn dann auch damit, dass er 3- bis 4-stellig pro vermittelten Spieler verdient. Also da sieht man die Dimensionen. Vielleicht sollten wir auf die jetzt auch dann an der Stelle mal kommen, weil wir jetzt so in klein vielen Beispielen waren. Was ist denn so die Gesamtdimension, die ihr dann für euren Probemonat oder für einen Stichprobemonat herausgerechnet habt?
Ja, wir hatten da in der Umfrage einen Freifeld, wo die Teilnehmenden angeben konnten, wie viel Geld sie eben bekommen und auf welchem Wege das passiert. Und da muss man glaube ich erstmal auch die Grundlagen so ein bisschen skizzieren. Da gibt es eben verschiedenste Möglichkeiten. Und das meiste oder das häufigste, was wir kennengelernt haben, waren dann so Mischzahlungsformen. Das heißt also Grundgehalt, in Anführungsstrichen, Punktprämien, Auflaufprämien. Und darüber haben dann eben die Spieler ihr Geld bezogen. Und dann haben wir natürlich dann das bereinigt und eben geschaut, wie können wir das jetzt berechnen, auf einen Monat bezogen. Eben auf diesen Monat, Oktober 2020. Und dann haben wir das ins Verhältnis gesetzt mit eben den 700.000 Amateurfußballern, die wir vorhin schon mal zitiert hatten, die eben allgemein im DFB spielen. Und dieses Verhältnis sah dann eben vor, dass wir, wenn alle genauso häufig und genauso viel Geld verdienen, da Summen haben, die bewegt werden von über 100 Millionen Euro im Amateurfußball in Deutschland. Und jetzt mag man erst mal denken, ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm, sind ja nur 700.000 Amateurfußballer und von denen kriegen auch nicht alle Geld. Von daher, warum jetzt der Aufschrei? Aber die Dimension ergibt sich dann eben, wenn man da jetzt noch mal ein weiteres Kriterium anlegt. Und dieses Kriterium ist dann eben die Frage nach der schriftlichen Dokumentation. Das heißt, ist es bar, ist es im Vertragsverhältnis, ist es irgendwo schriftlich dokumentiert, oder ist das der Klassiker eben am Monatsende der gefüllte Umschlag nach dem Freitagstraining im Vereinsheim oder so?
Und da kommt er eben auf irre hohe Zahlen. Die 100 Millionen hast du jetzt schon genannt. In jeder Saison soll es dann mehr als eine Milliarde Euro sein. Und wenn es ähnlich hoch wäre, wie jetzt in diesem Stichprobenmonat in der Befragung. Und ihr sprecht dann im Film davon, und da gehe ich davon aus, dass ihr das ja nicht nur statistisch überprüfen lasst, sondern auch juristisch, das ist bei solchen Recherchen ja dringend geboten, ihr sprecht von rund 500 Millionen Euro Schwarzgeld, die in jeder Saison fließen. Und ich glaube, da zeigt sich, was quasi mit salopp gesagt nur 300 Euro im Umschlag beginnt in der achten Spielklasse, summiert sich dann über den bundesdeutschen Fußball, Amateurfußball hinaus gesehen auf. Was droht denn dem Fußball jetzt aufgrund dieser Erkenntnisse?
Tja, das ist die große Frage, was jetzt droht. Also ich glaube, was wir jetzt haben, ist erstmal eine Diskussionsgrundlage, bei der wir uns alle die Frage stellen können, ist das das, was wir wollen? Ist das okay? Ist das zielführend? Ist das nachhaltig? Und die andere Frage ist natürlich, wie gehen wir damit um, dass eben etwa die Hälfte ungefähr davon mutmaßlich Schwarzgeld sein könnte. Also dass wir diese Zahlen dann erheben konnten, lag auch daran, dass wir eben genau danach gefragt haben. Und da war es eben sehr, sehr häufig so, dass wir von Barzahlungen gehört haben, von Zahlungen, die eben nicht schriftlich vereinbart waren. Deswegen haben wir aufgrund dieser Indizien und dieser Datenlage zu diesen Fragen dann diese Zahlen berechnen können. Und wir reden im Fußball in Deutschland immer viel über den Profibereich und die Kommerzialisierung, die dort stattfindet. Und wir reden über die Super League und Millionengehälter und die WM in Katar. Das ist auch alles berechtigt, das ist auch alles in Ordnung. Und ich finde aber, wir sollten trotz allem jetzt nicht die Augen davor verschließen, dass der Fußball auch in anderen Bereichen eben weiter unten in den Ligen durchaus kommerzialisiert ist. Dass es da finanzielle Interessen gibt. Woher die jetzt kommen, möchte ich jetzt gar nicht beantworten. Aber zumindest scheint das ja jetzt mit unseren Daten und nach unserer Recherche ein großes Thema zu sein. Und deswegen sollten sich Verbände damit auseinandersetzen. Es sollten sich auch Vereine damit auseinandersetzen, um eben mal zu überprüfen vielleicht, wie da so der eigene Stand ist. Wie viel des eigenen Etats man für die erste Herrenmannschaft ausgibt. Wie viel davon in vertraglich geregelten Verhältnissen stattfindet. Und wie viel eben nicht. Und auch Spieler sollten sich diese Frage stellen, denke ich. Denn natürlich ist es so, wo kein Kläger da kein Richter. Aber im Prinzip ist Steuerhinterziehung strafbar. Und Steuerhinterziehung findet eben dann statt, wenn ich meine Bezüge, die ich bekomme, nicht versteuere. Und da gehören eben auch Geldzahlungen, Sachwerte, Dienstleistungen. Alles, was wir in der Umfrage kennengelernt haben, dazu.
Der Journalismus kann ja im Grunde nur versuchen, Sachen herauszufinden, Sachen darzustellen, die vielleicht so nicht bekannt gewesen sind. Das ist uns jetzt hier in gewisser Weise gelungen, weil wir eben diese Zahlen erheben konnten. Und mithilfe, da komme ich nochmal mit einem kleinen Dank, mithilfe von Experten an zwei Universitäten in Dortmund und München auch hochrechnen könnten, so dass wir eben zu diesen hohen Zahlen kommen konnten. Und mehr können Journalisten eigentlich gar nicht machen. Wir geben diese Sache jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit und beobachten natürlich, ob es Diskussionen gibt. Wir werden auch darüber berichten. Es ist natürlich spannend, was damit passiert. Aber die Diskussionen, die müssen letztendlich, ja ich würde auch sagen, also Verbandsleute führen. Wir haben ja viele, viele Landesverbände und eben den Kopf, den Deutschen Fußballbund. Und denen müssen die Vereine führen. Und denen müssen möglicherweise auch Sportpolitiker führen.
Ein Punkt, weil er jetzt gerade mit rankam und einfach weil ich davon ausgehe, dass diese Sendung auch von Menschen gehört wird, die selbst im Amateursport aktiv sind. Sach- und Dienstleistungen sind eben auch ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt. Es geht nicht nur um das Bargeld im Umschlag, sondern auch andere Dienstleistungen, die man so gerade auf dem Dorf, also ich komme aus der dörflichen Umgebung, vielleicht komme ich deswegen immer auf diese Beispiele zurück, aber weil ich das eben dann eben auch gesehen habe. Also im Film nennt ihr als Beispiel auch irgendwie Grundstücke, die man dann bekommt oder reisen. Aber es fängt ja auch schon damit an, dass dann der Verein wird gesponsert von einem Sanitäranlagenbetreiber und der kommt dann einfach bei der Mannschaft vorbei und macht das mal einmal bei allen rund oder der Kaminkehrer kommt kostenlos. Das sind ja alles auch geldgleiche Dienstleistungen, die in der Regel nie gemeldet werden. Jetzt einfach meiner persönlichen Erfahrung nach und die sich da auch aussummieren können. Und ich fand das Beispiel von, jetzt muss ich gerade nochmal nachlesen, weil der Name auch so wunderbar war, habe ich es mir aufgeschrieben, das war Eintracht Waldmichelbach. Das war der Verein, wo eben die Steuerfahndung mal geklingelt hat und wo es auch eine harte Nachzahlung gab. Und ich finde, das wird schon relativ klar in diesem Film. Wenn jemand da draufblickt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann findet er wahrscheinlich mit ziemlich hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit etwas bei Amateurverein. Und dann kann das sehr, sehr schmerzhaft werden für alle Beteiligten. Über mögliche Haftungsfragen will ich da jetzt gar nicht reden, aber allein die Nachzahlungen, die da zu erwarten sind. Es ist eben kein Kabelliersdelikt.
Ja, bei Eintracht Waldmichelbach im Odenwald in Südhessen gelegen, da war es ein kleinerer 5-stelliger Betrag. Das ist in der Tat so. Und es gibt ja auch viele Vereine, die werden, ich sage jetzt mal, finanziell hochgerüstet und die fallen irgendwann. Die haben hohe Nachzahlungen, die können daran zerschellen und schaffen das irgendwie bis zur Oberliga. Und wenn der Sponsor dann abspringt oder vielleicht dann noch seine Schulden begleicht, die die Strafverfolger ihm dann bescheren bzw. die er sich selbst beschert hat, weil er eben keine Sozialabgaben bezahlt hat oder keine Stahlen bezahlt hat, wenn er sich dann zurückzieht, dann ist das ganze Spiel aus. Das ist einfach so. Und es gibt ja auch hin und wieder Urteile. Es gibt auch, wir lesen, wir kennen das auch alle, die wir uns für Fußball interessieren, für Lokalfußball interessieren, das ein bisschen verfolgen. Wir kennen auch hier und da, oh, da müssen Nachzahlungen, da gab es mal eine Razzia. Das gibt es ab und zu, aber es gibt es halt wenig. Weil natürlich die Strafverfolger erstmal einen Anpack finden müssen. Vielleicht kennt man noch den Verein der K.L.s in Baden. Die haben auch mal im Pokal, manch gegen Bayern München gespielt. Die haben den Dorfarzt, der offenbar vermögend genug ist, diesen Verein in größerem Maße zu sponsoren. Die haben den also als Präsidenten seit vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren, aber eben auch als Großsponsor. Bei denen hat es fünf Jahre gedauert. Vor fünf Jahren hat es ein Razzia gegeben, weil jemand, der offenbar damit in Berührung war, dass, ich sage jetzt mal, ohne dass ich es gesehen hätte, dieses Asservat in diesem Fall, der also, sage ich jetzt mal, das Lederbuch der Staatsanwälte oder Staatsanwälte oder Polizisten gegeben hat. Und da war eben eine Liste drin, soweit man das weiß, wo eben stand, Spieler X kriegt so und so viel, Spieler Y kriegt so und so viel. Und dann kam die Razzia. Und dann hat es lange, lange, lange Ermittlungen gegeben, der Staatsanwaltschaft Mannheim in diesem Fall. Und ja, dann hat es eben auch eine Rechtsprechung gegeben. Und da ist einiges nachzuzahlen gewesen. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie viel, aber eine erkleckliche Summe. Und das kann auf jeden Fall passieren. Das kann übrigens nicht passieren. Ich will das noch einmal, weil du das eben gesagt hast, oder red ich gerade zu lange? Nein, ich rede einfach mal weiter. Weil du eben die verdeckten Zahlungen genannt hast. Also irgendwelche Dienstleistungen. Das war für mich einer der Lieblingsstränge der Recherche. Ich fand das schon toll wie kreativ, toll in Anfangsstrichen, aber schon beeindruckend, sage ich mal, wie kreativ die Vereine oder auch die Mercedes, die das manchmal für die Vereine besorgen, in dieser Art der, wie soll ich sagen, Vergütung sind. Also klar, wir wissen, dass alle da kriegt ein Spieler ein Auto gestellt, ein geliesstes Auto. Da kann ein Spieler irgendwo, wenn er weiter weg wohnt, umsonst in einer Mietwohnung von irgendjemand in Vereinsnähe wohnen. Es gibt Tankkarten, es gibt aber auch zum Beispiel Stromgutscheine. Es gab wirklich zwei, drei Mal, das ist das in unserer Recherche begegnet, ein Baugrundstück. Also jemand schrieb, das war ganz am Anfang, weiß ich noch ganz genau, ich habe es gleich hier an die Kollegen mit Rechercheure weitergeleitet. Es gab den Eintrag, musste drei Jahre für ein Baugrundstück in der Landesliga spielen, habe das dann gemacht, habe mein Baugrundstück bekommen, bin dann zurück in die Kreisliga gegangen. Bumm, ja, den hätten wir gerne angerufen, der hat ja keinen Kontakt hinterlassen. Das war interessant, aber das haben mir zwei andere Leute dann auch noch erzählt. Alles mögliche, ja klar, auf der Terrasse werden Platten verlegt, also es gibt so viele, es gibt den Mini-Job für die Freundin, die dann aber gar nicht zur Arbeit gehen muss, sondern nur das Geld kriegt. Das haben wir öfter gehört und was wirklich offenbar ziemlich Routine inzwischen oder zumindest nicht ungewöhnlich ist, es gibt bei etwas höheren Vereinen, also ich sag jetzt mal siebte-, sechste-, fünfte Liga, da gibt es es auch die Einrichtung, dass ein Spieler einen Übungsleitervertrag bekommt. Er ist dann offiziell als E-Jugendtrainer angestellt, muss das aber natürlich nie machen und kriegt eben dann ganz legal oder zumindest auf dem Papier legal, ich sag mal lieber auf dem Papier legal, kriegt er dann halt sein Geld als E-Jugendtrainer, ohne dass er je die E-Jugend-Spieler zu Gesicht bekommen hat.
Kurz Ergänzung noch dazu, es gibt Vereine, wo das alle Spieler aus einer Mannschaft bekommen, die aber gar nicht so viele Jugendmannschaften haben, also die eigentlich gar nicht so viele Trainer bräuchten.
Es gibt auch Vereine mit drei Rasenwarten sozusagen, wo dann alle möglichen Leute den Rasen auch noch pflegen für 250 Euro oder so. Ja, kreativ geht es da zur Sache.
Habt ihr eine Idee, warum das so selten zur Aufdeckung kommt, oder zumindest so selten, dass diese Recherche jetzt noch das ganze Ausmaß so klar machen kann? Ihr habt ja auch einen Insider, der mit euch gesprochen hat, der den Hintergrund aus dem Strafverfolgungsbereich im Finanzwesen hat.
Ja, der Insider war tatsächlich sehr spannend dann im Gespräch, denn das ist jemand, der eben diese Einblicke hat in Amateurfußball und der gleichzeitig aus seiner beruflichen Praxis zu berichten wusste. Und in den Erstgesprächen habe ich schon festgestellt, klar muss man erst mal verstehen, Schwarzzahlungen nachzuweisen ist halt sehr, sehr schwierig. Denn wenn Geld im Umlauf ist in bar, dann wird das auch schnell wieder ausgegeben. Das ist jetzt nichts, was irgendwie dann angelegt wird oder was auch immer. Das heißt, das ist erstmal eine große Herausforderung für die Finanzbehörden. Und wir haben dann weiterhin eben versucht, auch in Kontakt zu treten mit den Finanzministerien der Bundesländer, um dort eben mal zu erfragen, wie häufig sie Steuerprüfungen durchführen bei gemeinnützigen Vereinen, eben auch im Fußball, im Amateurfußball. Und da war eben überwiegend der Tenor, dass das kein Prüfungsschwerpunkt sei und dass eben auch keine Statistiken dazu geführt würden. Das heißt, wir könnten jetzt noch nicht mal sagen, wie häufig Amateurvereine in Deutschland geprüft würden. Turnusmäßig soll das, glaube ich, alle drei Jahre passieren, so ist mein Stand. Aber was passiert jetzt, wenn es Hinweise gibt? Oder was passiert jetzt stichprobenartig? Das konnte in der Form jetzt niemand so richtig beantworten. Und das hat dann eben auch nochmal aufgezeigt, dass die Aufdeckungswahrscheinlichkeit eben sehr gering ist, weil eben die 500 plus x Finanzämter, die wir in Deutschland haben, sich auf andere Branchen fokussieren. Ich denke, das ist eine Erkenntnis, die wir auch mitnehmen können, dass eben die Baubranche, die Finanzdienstleistungsbranche, Banken und so weiter eher im Fokus der Finanzämter und auch dann der Prüfungen, der Steuerprüfungen entstehen. Sodass eben im Amateurfußball weniger stattfindet und dann obendrauf noch, wenn etwas stattfindet, das Ganze nicht so dokumentiert wird, dass man da valide Zahlen zur Verfügung hätte. Und das ist dann natürlich auch die Frage, okay, wie gehen wir jetzt damit um? Ja, auch politisch, auch rechtlich, auch verbandseitig. Was schaffen wir jetzt für Regelungen? Machen wir es eventuell einfacher für die Vereine, damit umzugehen? Befreien wir sie komplett von der Pflicht, irgendwie im Transparenzregister aufzutauchen? Oder was auch immer. Da gibt es ja dann verschiedenste Konstrukte. Aber unter dem Strich ist es eben so, dass das Ehrenamt am Ende abfedern muss, was an den Regelungen aktuell passiert. Und da ist eben auch eine Erkenntnis, dass ein Ehrenamtler, der jetzt die Auszahlungen verwaltet für eine erste Herrenmannschaft, im Zweifel immer den illegalen Weg wählt, einfach weil es weniger Aufwand bedeutet und auch weniger kostet am Ende.
Aber prinzipiell ist es natürlich so, wir haben hier in einem Bereich der Gesellschaft recherchiert, der gar nicht so sehr auf den ersten Blick dazu taucht, und auf dem zweiten auch nicht, der Böse zu sein. Bei rechten Parteien oder in der Finanzbranche habe ich mal recherchiert. Teilweise auch bei der Wettmafia im Fußball. Das sind alles Bereiche, wo man ganz klar sagen kann oder auch fordern kann, warum wird da nicht noch genauer hingeguckt, warum gibt es da nicht noch mehr Kontrollen. Das kann natürlich auch keinem einzigen Amateurverein schaden, dass er kontrolliert wird, nur umgekehrt. Ich denke, das ist eine Reaktion, die vielleicht die Zuhörer und die Zuschauer vom Film haben und die ich auch gleich wieder spüre, als Arne das gerade gesagt hat. Es ist ja auch kein böser Bereich. Das Beispiel Eintracht Waldmichelbach, das du eben noch mal genannt, Max. Zumindest, wir stecken nicht in den Köpfen der handelnden Akteure, aber wenn man sie sieht, wie sie reden, wie sie das beteuern, kann man sich fast nicht vorstellen, dass die da wirklich planmäßig... Die wussten so ein bisschen, dass da nicht alles ganz in Ordnung ist, aber letztendlich haben sie immer weitergemacht und gesagt, es ist doch für den Fußball, es ist doch für gute. Die anderen machen es auch alle. Es ist völlig falsch, im Journalismus von Gegnern zu sprechen, wenn man recherchiert, sondern es sind ja Themen und es sind Akteure, mit denen man zu tut. Bei dieser Recherche hatten wir teilweise auch, ich hab das zumindest so empfunden, furchtbar sympathische Akteure, wo man dann sagen würde, ist auch nicht alles ganz sauber, aber irgendwie, ja komm, so ein ganz bisschen Restverständnis kommt manchmal auf, man ist ja auch nur ein Mensch, ein Journalist.
Also bei mir ehrlich gesagt, war das bei vielen Protagonisten in diesem Film so, gab da ein paar Ausnahmen, da können wir vielleicht noch gleich drüber sprechen, aber weil man ja auch weiß, wie das in Amateurvereinen läuft. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sich da 15 ausgebildete Steuerprüfer darum bewerben, Kassenwart zu sein, sondern irgendjemand muss es machen. Der wird gewählt, der wird mehr schlecht als recht wahrscheinlich von seinem Vorgänger eingewiesen und da steht halt dann drauf, wir rechnen hier immer Reisekosten ab. Das ist halt das Honorar, was Spiele XY bekommt und dann machst du das einfach weiter und beschäftigst dich damit gar nicht und denkst vielleicht auch gar nicht über die Konsequenzen nach beziehungsweise auch über die Frage, wieviel komplizierter und verlustreicher wäre es eigentlich, das auf anderem Wege abzurechnen. Und da, finde ich, kommen wir dann ja relativ schnell in die Situation, dass man nach der Rolle der Landesverbände und des DFBs fragen müsste. Denn wenn ich mir diesen Film und die Erkenntnisse daraus angucke, dann müsste ja eigentlich die nächste Handlung der Landesverbände und des DFBs sein. Ja, wir müssen so wie wir in ganz vielen anderen Bereichen des Amateur- und Breitensports auch mit Anreichungen, mit Schulungen, mit Fortbildungen, mit allem Möglichen an Informationskampagnen einfach die Vereine davor schützen, Fehler zu machen. Das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich der nächste Schritt sein. Und gleichzeitig stellt sich die interessante Frage, warum gibt es das eigentlich noch nicht? Denn wenn man über das Thema nachdenkt, kommt man eigentlich sehr schnell darauf, dass hier etwas wahrscheinlich nicht so gut läuft, auch wenn die Dimensionen überraschend sind. Aber ich würde jetzt einfach die These aufstellen. Jeder, der im Amateursport ein paar Jahre unterwegs war, der hat da solche Dinge gesehen, er hat es bloß wahrscheinlich noch nicht mit dem richtigen Problembewusstsein wahrgenommen. Aber dem DFB und den Landesverbänden muss ich ja unterstellen, dass sie dafür ein Problembewusstsein haben. Gerade mit der Vorgeschichte dieser Verbände.
Ja, glaube ich auf jeden Fall. Wir haben das vor allem ja bei der Pillenkick-Recherche über Schmerzmittel eben auch Amateurfußball ja gesehen. Da gab es hinterher der DFB relativ fix reagiert und hat Seminare angeboten, hat Experten losgeschickt, die darüber aufgeklärt haben, was es bedeutet, immer wieder oder auch regelmäßig, um sportlich, fußballisch aktiv werden zu können, Schmerzmittel zu nehmen. Und da hat man auf Verbandsseite eben den Eindruck gehabt, da ist noch nicht genug aufgeklärt worden, da besteht Nachholbedarf. Und ich glaube schon, dass das hier auch so ist. Es wird jetzt spannend sein zu beobachten, wer sich da verantwortlich fühlt. Die DFB, wir haben zwischendurch mal bei der Recherche, weil wir einfach mal wissen wollten, wie sieht der DFB das eigentlich? Also irgendwann zwischendurch haben wir mal eine Anfrage gestellt, eine Recherche-Anfrage und haben gefragt und die haben gesagt, ja, natürlich sind die dagegen, oder ist der DFB, die Verbandsspitze, dagegen, dass in den untersten Ligen sehr viel Geld bezahlt wird, aber ansonsten hat er zum einen auf die Landesverbände und zum anderen aber auch ganz klar auf den Gesetzgeber verwiesen, ja, und auch auf die Vereine, ja, natürlich. Und da hat der DFB vielleicht auch nicht völlig unrecht, ja, die Frage ist jetzt immer, kann er nicht trotzdem was daran ändern, aber er sagt natürlich dann durch die Blume, die Vereine müssen sehen, dass sie das alles ordentlich hinkriegen.
Ja, natürlich herrscht in Deutschland Vereinsautonomie, und es ist auch als Verband dann nicht so einfach, in einen Verein hinein zu agieren und da irgendwas zu erwirken, ja, aber das lässt sich denke ich dann schon machen, wenn man eben das Bewusstsein schafft für ein Problem, wenn man eben aufklärt über dieses Problem. Und das ist dann eben die entscheidende Frage. Und da wiederum muss ich sagen, bin ich eher skeptisch, was die Reaktion des DFB und auch der Landesverbände betrifft, denn natürlich haben wir alle mitbekommen in den letzten Jahren, was dort noch so diskutiert wird an Compliance, Good Governance und Intrigitätsthemen. Deswegen weiß ich gar nicht. Also ich lasse mich gerne vom Gegenteil überzeugen, aber ich weiß tatsächlich nicht zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, inwieweit es jetzt, wenn wir uns in einem oder in zwei Jahren wieder treffen und da nochmal Bilanz ziehen, was hat sich denn jetzt verändert, ob sich dann wirklich was verändert hat. Denn natürlich malen die Mühlen gesetzgeberisch sehr langsam. Und auch der DFB als riesengroßer Tanker mit wahnsinnig vielen Partikularinteressen, die da eine Rolle spielen, der schafft das jetzt auch nicht einfach, so mal in 25.000 Vereine hineinzuwirken mit einem schlüssigen und tragfähigen Konzept, um diesem Problem irgendwie herzuwerden.
Wobei ich wäre, weiß ich nicht, man soll ja immer das gute Menschen glauben und das Gute im Verband glauben. Ich glaube, die Power wäre schon da. Die Power wäre schon da, denn wenn sich so ein großer und letztendlich immer noch sehr reicher und sehr potenter Verband wie der Deutsche Fußballbund etwas vornimmt, dann kann er das natürlich machen. Die Frage ist, ob er es wirklich zu seiner eigenen Sache macht, auf seine Agenda packt. Und ich glaube, das hast du ja schon gerade angedeutet, Arne. Die Agenda ist natürlich proppenvoll beim DFB im Moment.
Letzter Satz dazu von mir. Vielleicht hat ja die Agentur Freshfields Zeit, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Die sind aber ganz schön teuer, Arne. Das kriegen wir auch billiger hin.
Das Geld ist doch da am Amtkopf.
Dann mache ich einen Flyer, den man irgendwie per Meteor verschickt. Wir haben das schon vorhin angesprochen. Aber zu diesem Punkt kommt man immer wieder zurück, dass man sich fragt, gibt es denn keine größeren Probleme, als Dorfverein XY, der 1000 Euro im Monat unter seinen drei besten Spielern verteilt? Natürlich gibt es größere Probleme. Gleichzeitig finde ich schon spannend das, was ihr auch schon gesagt habt. In anderen Bereichen des Fußballs, nämlich im Leistungssport, kritisieren wir, sage ich jetzt einfach mal als kollektives Wir, Kommerzialisierung sehr stark, sind sehr kritisch bei vielen Themen. Und gleichzeitig sind wahrscheinlich manche der Kritiker dann auf dieser lokalen Ebene entweder so blauäugig, dass sie es nicht sehen oder so, dass sie dafür dann doch Rechtfertigung finden. Und die Frage ist halt schon, warum soll das eigentlich unterschiedlich behandelt werden? Und beim DFB und den Landesverbänden finde ich es insofern besonders erstaunlich, weil Steuern und diese Verbände und die Gemeinnützigkeit einfach schon seit Beginn dieser Verbände ein Thema ist. Also das ist, egal ob du in die 60er, die 70er, die 80er oder die 90er oder in die Jetztzeit schaust, es war immer ein Thema, egal ob es um die Vergnügungssteuer ging, ob es um Umsatzsteuer ging und die Gemeinnützigkeit war immer ein wichtiger Aspekt, weil da eben einfach enorme steuerliche und auch sonstige Vorteile aus dieser Gemeinnützigkeit erwachsen. Und der DFB hat sie ja auch schon mal entzogen bekommen. Also der ist ja auch schon mal ganz, ganz fürchterlich auf die Nase gefallen mit diesem Thema. Und das ist dann doch, finde ich, irgendwie erstaunlich, auch wenn der DFB natürlich jetzt nicht verantwortlich sein kann für jeden einzelnen Kassenwart in diesem Land. Das ist mir schon völlig klar, aber es ist dann doch irgendwie erstaunlich, dass es immer noch blinde Flecken zu geben scheint in diesem Bereich. Oder bin ich da jetzt zu kritisch?
Nee, ich würde das ganz ähnlich definieren, dieses Problem. Also ich möchte eben auch nochmal zu bedenken geben, dass es ja an der Basis, wie man so schön sagt, durchaus Menschen gibt, die dieses Problem auch sehen und die dann in einer Arbeitsgruppe bei einem Landesverband mal was anstoßen wollen. Mal sagen wollen, okay, wir machen jetzt hier eine Arbeitsgruppe, wir wollen dieses Thema mal lösen. Und irgendwann muss das natürlich an die Verbandsspitze gehen. Und dann muss die Verbandsspitze etwas entscheiden, ob dann genügend Ressourcen weiterhin dafür zur Verfügung stehen oder ob das Thema größer gedacht wird oder nicht. Und da gibt es viele, viele Menschen, die eigentlich das Gute im Sinn haben und die eine Veränderung bewirken wollen, die aber dann eben an den Gegebenheiten scheitern in den Verbänden. Und das ist natürlich dann auch ein Problem. Wenn wir uns Führungsstrukturen anschauen, wenn wir uns tradierte Verhaltensweisen anschauen innerhalb der Verbände, das macht es ja dann nicht einfacher. Und wenn es jetzt eben Bestrebungen gibt innerhalb der Community des Amateurfußballs, die Situation zu verändern, dann sollte der Verein das auch, oder der Verband, Entschuldigung, sollte der Verband das ermöglichen. Denn ich glaube, es würde, wenn überhaupt, eher bottom-up als top-down geschehen, wenn sich da etwas verändert. Also das wird, wenn, dann eher von unten kommen, anstatt von oben.
Ja, interessanter Gedanke. Und gleichzeitig, und da kann ich wirklich nur jedem empfehlen, schaut euch diesen Film an. Ich sag's nochmal, Milliarden-Geschäft Amateurfußball, wenn das Geld im Umschlag kommt, ist heute Abend um 23.30 Uhr in der ARD zu sehen und in der Mediathek zu finden. Da habt ihr ja auch einen Investor und den haben wir auch im Intro gehört. Deswegen möchte ich nochmal kurz erklären, wen haben wir da eigentlich gehört. Das war Gerhard Klapp, Unternehmer und Millionär, der in seiner Region sechs Fußballvereine unterstützt und im Intro haben wir eben gehört, dass er sagt, er hat da eineinhalb bis zwei Millionen Euro hinein investiert und auf die Frage, ja aber sind denn diese Vereine nicht irgendwie von Ihnen abhängig, sagte er, ja das will ich aber doch sehr hoffen, weil ansonsten würde ich ja nicht investieren. Und das kann man sogar, finde ich, da muss man jetzt nicht Rollenspieler sein, um das aus seiner Sicht total nachvollziehen zu können. Aber das zeigt ja auch, welche abstruse Blüten das eben auch in den 5., 6., 7., Rundenliegen dieses Landes sprießen lässt. Denn im Grunde ist das nichts anderes, als wenn Martin Kind oder Dietmar Hopp oder irgendjemand anderes auch versucht, einem Bundesligisten als Investor so an sich zu binden, dass man die Entscheidungsbefugnis hat. Es ist halt nur in einer anderen Liga und so, dass wir es, wenn ihr nicht gerade einen Film drüber macht, nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, also das hat die Recherche auf jeden Fall ganz eindeutig gebracht. Die sogenannten Mini-Hopps, die immer mal wieder von Zeitungen dann entdeckt werden in den Regionen, die gibt es einfach und es wäre naiv, zu glauben, dass die jetzt gar nicht mitbestimmen, dass die einfach nur sagen, ich gebe immer das Geld, aber macht mal so, wie ihr meint. Das glaube ich nicht, das wird in den allerseltensten Fällen sicherlich auch mal der Fall sein. Aber auch Dietmar Hopp hat sich ja immer so ein bisschen, zumindest ich habe das mal eine Zeit lang verfolgt in den allerersten Jahren, als er auf dem Leim aufgestiegen ist in die Bundesliga, damals als Journalist und Dietmar Hopp hat sich ja auch immer so ein bisschen, ich mach doch gar nicht, ich gucke doch nur und ich stehe doch hier nur auf der Tribüne, aber im Hintergrund sitzt der Spielerberater, widmen in der Loge und da werden natürlich in solchen Logen dann auch immer mal wieder Fäden gezogen. Also die Leute mischen mit und das hat der Gerhard Klapp, der jetzt der mit zehn war, den wir ausgewählt haben, für diesen Film und der uns freundlicherweise eben auch, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Einblick in sein Tun gewährt hat.
Und sein Fuhrpark auch?
In seinen Fuhrpark am Rande und auch in seine Mannschaften und auch in die Gehälter, die gezahlt werden, das hat der also ganz klar gesagt.
Also wirklich, das fand ich so der Protagonist, der mir einfach jetzt in den Tagen, nach dem ich diese Doku gesehen habe, immer im Blick geblieben ist zusammen mit den Eintrachtwald Mittelbachern, den beiden, an die habe ich mich erinnert und Arne an jemanden, an den ich mich auch erinnert habe und den haben wir eben auch im Intro gehört, war Thomas Sommerer, ein Sportjurist, dem ihr eure Recherche vorgelegt habt und das habt prüfen lassen und der eben gesagt hat, naja, das könnte ein Erdbeben auslösen und er sagt nicht nur, dass den Vereinen der Entzug der Gemeinnützigkeit droht, sondern auch Spieler könnten Probleme kriegen, denn sie müssen auch Sachbezüge versteuern. Steuerhinterziehung, da gibt es bis zu fünf Jahren Freiheitsstrafe oder Geldstrafe, ohne jetzt davon ausgehen zu wollen, dass das jetzt auch schon ein realistisches Strafmaß mehr. Aber ich glaube, diesen Punkt muss man an der Stelle schon auch noch machen, wenn ein Finanzamt hinschaut und wenn ein Finanzamt sieht, hier wurde, so wie es ja offenbar in vielen Vereinen passiert oder dem Anschein nach in vielen Vereinen passiert, etwas nicht korrekt versteuert, dann betrifft das nicht nur den Verein, sondern es kann auch auf den Spieler zurückfallen.
Ganz genau, und das ist, glaube ich, eine der zentralen Themen auch, die uns dann beschäftigen muss. Das ist eben die Mischung aus Sportrecht und Stafrecht, die dann eben zum Tragen kommt. Natürlich weist die Spielordnung des DFB auch aus. Ich meine, ich mich zu erinnern, dass im schlimmsten Fall ein Verein auch bestraft werden kann für so etwas mit einem Punktabzug oder so, also dass halt da schon eine Möglichkeit besteht, müsste ich jetzt aber nochmal nachschauen, weiß nicht genau, aber andererseits im strafrechtlichen Bereich ist das natürlich auch alles relevant, also auf dem Papier wäre es ja schon so, wenn jetzt die Aufdeckungswahrscheinlichkeit viel viel höher wäre, dass dann theoretisch mehr Leute einfach bestraft werden würden und auch mehr Vereine Nachzahlungen leisten müssten. Jetzt haben wir eben schon diskutiert, warum das nicht der Fall ist, aber ich kann eben aus der Erfahrung schildern, dass wir mit vielen Betroffenen gesprochen haben, die das tatsächlich auch wissen, so und die das wissen, dass das Schwarzgeld ist, die das teilweise ärgert, die das teilweise aber auch eher mit Axelzucken dann hinnehmen, dass es so ist, weil sie eben schon erahnen, dass es eben nicht so leicht aufgedeckt werden kann und das ist eben ein juristischer Graubereich, in dem eben auch noch nicht so viel Rechtsprechung vorliegt. Wenn ich mich jetzt an die Gespräche mit Herrn Summerer erinnere, der hatte sich dann so verschiedenste Fallbeispiele angeschaut, die wir ihm aufbereitet hatten und ist dann eben zu diesem Schluss gekommen und das bringt eben dann noch mal eine weitere Komponente mit rein. Also wir hatten diese gesellschaftliche Komponente schon diskutiert, welche Rolle spielte Amateurfußball in Deutschland, wir hatten die sportliche Komponente, wir hatten die finanzielle Komponente und jetzt haben wir noch eine juristische Komponente. Das zeigt eben, wie komplex dieses Thema auch ist und wie viele unterschiedliche Bereiche unseres Lebens damit zu tun haben. Und letztinstanzlich, wenn ich mich der Steuerhinterziehung strafbar mache, dann begehe ich eben ein Verbrechen und das sollte schon jeder irgendwo wissen, denn wenn wir keine Steuern zahlen würden in unserer Gesellschaft, dann hätten wir ganz andere Probleme. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt hier die Steuern irgendwie an sich das Problem wären, sondern diese Gelder werden ja schon meistens zumindest an den Stellen eingesetzt, an denen sie gebraucht werden.
Außer Andreas Scheuer hat da irgendwie mitzureden, aber das ist jetzt eine ganz persönliche Meinung. Was wird denn jetzt eurer Meinung nach passieren oder was sind jetzt erstmal eure konkreten Pläne? Seid ihr jetzt schon komplett fertig mit eurer Recherche? Bleibt die Umfrage zum Beispiel offen? Es könnte ja jetzt auch sein, dass jetzt dann durch den ARD-Film angeregt sich ganz andere Leute noch mal bei euch melden. Wie geht es für euch weiter?
Also für uns ist es natürlich fast unmöglich, würde ich sagen, sich jetzt gleich davon zu trennen. Wir haben uns jetzt so intensiv damit beschäftigt. Das ist ja dann irgendwie fast ein kleines Baby, so eine Langzeitrecherche. Und wir verfolgen das jetzt, werden sicherlich auch zeitnah einmal berichten, möglicherweise schon am Wochenende mit ersten Reaktionen, wenn denn was passiert. Und werden das aber auch im Blick behalten. Und ich hoffe auch, dass sich weiterhin Leute bei uns melden, die ihre Erfahrungen mitteilen, die was zu sagen haben. Vielleicht jetzt auch keine Ahnung, soll jetzt hier kein Aufruf sein, aber es ist spannend. Warum nicht? Ja, warum nicht, stimmt. Wir wollen weiter mit den Leuten im Gespräch sein und von ihren Erfahrungen profitieren, unser Wissen erweitern. Und so können wir das eben journalistisch aufbereiten und journalistisch mit den Mitteln von Journalisten einordnen.
Bleibt die Umfrage offen?
Ja, wir hatten eben die Umfrage die ganze Zeit noch offen gelassen. Und da ist auch immer wieder dann irgendwas reingetrudelt, aber die wurde jetzt ja nicht mehr aktiv beworben. Aber grundsätzlich ist sie schon noch offen, das heißt also, wenn uns Leute etwas erzählen wollen, schreiben wollen, können sie das dort tun. Ich glaube, wir müssen sie mal so ein bisschen frisch machen wieder. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich in den letzten Monaten so ein bisschen liegen geblieben, weil wir eben andere Aufgaben hatten. Aber grundsätzlich ist es eben auch wichtig, dass man uns dann in irgendeiner Form erreichen kann, auch anonym. Weil das ist eben auch wichtig, so dieser Bereich der journalistischen Recherche, dass man anonym eben Sachen hinterlassen kann, Dokumente hochladen kann, Erfahrungsberichte teilen kann. Und natürlich das Bessere für uns ist natürlich, wenn Leute mit Kontaktdaten dort was hinterlassen, weil dann haben wir eben die Möglichkeit, mit den Leuten in Kontakt zu treten. Und das war eben kurz angeklungen, aber ich habe noch mal so grob überschlagen, wie viele Gespräche wir geführt hatten, so Telefongespräche. Und ich bin dann addiert irgendwo so zwischen 250 und 350 rausgekommen, also so plus minus. Und das zeigt so ein bisschen, wie viele Leute wir da wirklich genervt haben mit dem Thema zum Teil.
Jetzt kriegst du da einen Aufruf, Max. Also wirklich Expressis Verbis. Meldet euch gerne über diese Umfrage bei uns und das wird diskret behandelt. Nennt gerne, wenn ihr was zu sagen habt und nicht alles hinschreiben wollt, einen Kontakt, eine Kontaktmöglichkeit. Und was da geschrieben wird, wird definitiv nicht veröffentlicht, sondern nur, wenn solltet ihr da zustimmen, dass das veröffentlicht wird. Aber es ist wie gesagt einfach wichtig, dass man in Kontakt kommt.
Wird alles verlinkt werden in den Show Notes und dann schaut alle die Doku um 23.30 Uhr am Mittwoch, den 19. Januar in der ARD und natürlich auch in der Mediathek zu sehen. Und dann bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie lange ihr an diesem Thema noch dran sein werdet. Ich bin auch schon gespannt, mit was ihr mich dann in anderthalb Jahren wieder überraschen werdet. Das scheint ja jetzt so ein neues Ding zu werden, dass ihr irgendwo den Teppich anhebt des Sports und dann darunter ein bisschen was findet, was manche als nicht sagt, ganz so sauber bezeichnen würden und dann sprechen wir hier im Rasenfunk drüber und ein Jahr später kommt ihr dann mit dem nächsten Teppicheck und bin immer gespannt. Oder wollt ihr schon verraten, woran ihr jetzt gerade arbeitet?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir sind jetzt erstmal noch hier, Gott bewahre.
Na, ich werde euch an euren Worten messen. Dann danke ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ich danke euch für den Aufwand, den ihr auch in diese Recherche gesteckt habt. Ich denke, das ist auch wichtig, nochmal zu betonen. Das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Schön, dass es dann sowas auch gibt, dass das in der ARD gezeigt werden kann und dass ihr das bei Eyeopening Media alles so verfolgen könnt. Das ist ein wichtiger Teil des deutschen Sportjournalismus. Ich danke euch beiden ganz herzlich. Arne Steinberg, et Steinberg unterstrich Arne auf Twitter. Danke dir Arne, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank an dich Max und liebe Grüße und danke nochmal an alle, die über den Rasenfunk an der Umfrage teilgenommen haben.
Ja, das schließe ich mich an. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Wigbert Löer, der Ed Wigbert Löer auch auf Twitter. Ihr habt das schön einfach gehalten mit den Twitter-Händels. Danke dir, Wigbert.
Ja, vielen Dank auch an dich und an euch, alle, die jetzt zugehört haben.
Ja, euch danke ich auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euren Support. Wie immer habe ich auch noch zwei Podcast-Empfehlungen am Ende dieser Folge, die jetzt einfach aus meinem persönlichen Podcast-Konsum der letzten Tage kommen. Zum einen, das passt sogar, der Sport Inside Podcast hat über Wettbetrug im Tennis eine Folge veröffentlicht. Die kann ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen und dann etwas komplett anderes. Der No-Fucking-Regrets-Podcast mit Rob Flimm von Machine Head hat John Petrucci von Dream Theater interviewt. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen nischig, mir persönlich hat die Folge aber sehr gut gefallen. Also diese beiden Podcast-Folgen möchte ich euch ans Ohr legen und ansonsten hören wir uns hier wieder im Rasenfunk in einem unserer Formate. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, macht's gut!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkhäuser.